And her first class is "Intergalactic Revolutionaries and You,"
and America is so excited, she's ready to show off her strength,
she's ready to show off her portal-punching skills,
(Laughter)
and I stripped that safety net from her right away.
And I limited her powers, and I changed up her location
and shook up her world, because that is what college is like,
(Laughter)
especially if you're alone.
But I didn't want America to be alone for long,
and so in a homework assignment gone totally wrong,
she lands on a battlefield with the X-Men.
(Laughter)
Because, when I was in college,
the Reverend Kelly Brown Douglas was my mentor,
and I knew that America Chavez needed one, too.
And who better to mentor America Chavez than Storm,
the first black female superhero
and one of the most powerful members of the X-Men?
Nobody, that's who.
(Laughter)
And Storm teaches America how to quiet her mind
inside of a star portal,
and when America quiets her mind, she opens up the dimensions,
and in that silence,
she can listen for anything and anyone.
And no one has ever offered her silence and deep reflection
as a way to be powerful.
And at first, she rejects it, but with Storm's encouragement,
it clicks,
and America quiets the world around her,
and she leans into a deep vulnerability.
I mean, her and Storm even hug.
I know.
And that's because my mentors loved me enough
to encourage me to investigate myself and my ancestors,
and when you're 19, how do you even know what that means?
I didn't learn about the history of my people in college.
I learned about the history of my people sitting on my grandmother's lap
when she pulled out the photo album
and she named everyone that was here and everyone still left on the island.
So obviously, I had to crash-land a grandma on America Chavez,
and not just any grandma -- a big, strong, luchador grandma,
one that loved her enough to take her to the ancestral plain,
where America Chavez could see the history of her people
play out in the skies above.
And America gets to see Planeta Fuertona,
the birth planet of her grandmother,
and she sees it get invaded,
and she sees her grandmother and her mom flee.
And she also sees the joy that they experience
when their new homeland accepts them openly
and offers them tremendous care.
She gets to see great pain met with even greater compassion,
and that's right alongside the tremendous strength of her family.
And so everywhere that I could, right,
I wrote her little love notes
for her and for all the other queer kids of color
trying to be magnificent.
Like, when you lose yourself,
dig deep into your ancestry, because you will find the pieces there.
And also, reminders that soft is not a pass to duck,
to hide, to be silent, to cower.
Soft is also a push
to hold ourselves accountable.
Kind of like when America lands in World War II
and comes face-to-face with Hitler,
and she knocks him the hell out ...
(Laughter)
just like Captain America did in 1941,
and who knew we'd need America Chavez to punch Nazis in 2018.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
And even that, that justified act kind of wrecks her a little bit,
so I made sure that she linked up with her best friend,
and they talk feelings and they go on a road trip
and they sing "Just a Girl" by No Doubt at the top of their lungs.
(Laughter)
And when Midas, a sinister corporation,
takes control of Sotomayor,
threatens to ban portals and almost kills America ...
her ancestors reach for her ...
because they know that she needs to heal.
And it is that burst of care, that healing, that gives her the fuel
to defeat Midas and reclaim herself.
See, because that myth
of having to go it alone and having to be tough ...
doesn't serve us.
America Chavez is a whole superhero,
and she still needed a team of support to help her find herself.
And she needed that gentleness,
the type of gentleness that is rooted in compassion
and still very much invested in justice and liberation.
Because it's in that space where softness and vulnerability meet strength
that we transcend our everyday selves,
that we become something greater, something majestic,
maybe even something super.
Thank you.
(Applause)